18000 contamination au cours des
dernières 24 heures
la tendance n'est pas bonne c'est dans
ce contexte un peu plus d'une semaine
après les annonces des manuels macron
que le projet de loi sur l'obligation
vaccinale et l'extension du pass
sanitaire était débattue ce mardi au
parlement
à ceux qui voudraient contester la
légitimité des nouvelles mesures de
restriction
jean castex a exposé ses intentions
je voudrais dire à la représentation
nationale que sur l'ensemble du texte
dont vous êtes désormais saisie je
saisirai le conseil constitutionnel car
n'en doutez pas notre objectif comme
toujours a été de prendre des mesures
proportionnées à la situation sanitaire
garantissant les libertés publiques
fondamentales et assurant le
développement de la sécurité sanitaire
une prise de position franches du
premier ministre tout sauf anodine
le week-end dernier plus de cent mille
personnes ont manifesté contre
l'adoption du pass sanitaires car selon
elle les nouvelles restrictions qu'ils
engendrent représente une atteinte à la
liberté
une position également partagée par une
partie de la classe politique comme la
france insoumise
on s'y oppose à la fois pour des
questions de liberté mais à la fois
parce que sur le long cours on pense que
c'est pas la bonne manière de convaincre
les français de l'année cité du vaccin
ce qui est indispensable mais également
j'allais dire d'utiliser d'autres
d'autres outils pour lutter contre les
piliers parce qu'il y en a d'autres là
il faut un arsenal complet dont le
vaccin est là on est dans une politique
de contraintes d'obligations et de
contrôle généralisé qui à mon avis
frappe il de mal que de bien
alors que le texte prévoit une mise en
application du pass sanitaire dès le
premier round dans les bars et
restaurants
les républicains demandent une
dérogation jusqu'au 30 août pour ceux
ayant reçu une première dose de vaccin
d'autres mesures concernant le quotidien
ne trouve pas grâce non plus aux yeux du
principal groupe d'opposition rentrer
dans un café acheter son journal
et est-ce qu'il faut vraiment impasse
sanitaire ça pose de vraies questions
prendre le train aller dans un centre
commercial tout ça ce sont des éléments
importante maintenant on a plutôt un
gouvernement qui pousse à vitesse grand
v un ministre vers ans qui ne cherchent
pas manifestement à trop entendre les
arguments des uns et des autres et qui
trouve que déjà on traîne trop il ya un
moment où le parlement doit pouvoir
aussi travailler bien que le
gouvernement ne veuille plus perdre de
temps le pass sanitaire doit encore être
débattue tout au long de cette semaine
le texte sera examiné dans l'hémicycle
de l'assemblée nationale mercredi puis
au sénat jeudi en vue de son adoption
définitive en fin de semaine